in 1943 the uss eldridge was made
invisible and teleported from
philadelphia to virginia and this event
was known as the philadelphia experiment
when the eldridge reappeared some crew
materialized in walls and bulk heads and
they died in agony but two sailors
didn't reappear at all the two men who
happen to be brothers were presumed dead
or lost
they weren't dead they traveled 40 years
into the future into a secret military
base on the east end of long island they
became unwitting participants of the
montauk project
[Music]
in the early 70s preston nichols an
engineer who specialized in
electromagnetism worked for a defense
contractor on long island and during
this time he was working with a group of
psychics studying telepathy and getting
good results he discovered that
telepathy behaves exactly like a radio
wave for some reason at the same time
every day his subject's minds would be
blocked and he had no idea why after
three years of the strange phenomenon
nichols brought in radio equipment to
monitor the signals during the psychic
blackout
he learned that whenever 410 to 420
megahertz was detected his subjects were
jammed and after 20 minutes the signal
would dissipate and the psychics would
open back up nichols built a mobile
transceiver and tracked the origin of
the signal to montauk point on the east
end of long island new york more
specifically he traced the signal to a
large radar tower on montauk air force
base so there was nothing he could do
about it the radio interference
continued for a few years and eventually
stopped nichols didn't give it much
thought until he received a call from a
friend who said the air force base was
now abandoned and he should go check it
out and the base was deserted but for
some reason it was a mess you would
expect the military to decommission a
base in a clean and orderly way but not
montauk it was as if whoever was working
here cleared out in a hurry
and after exploring nichols came across
a young homeless man who was living in
one of the abandoned buildings the young
man acted nervous he said he was a
military technician who worked there but
he deserted when a large beast appeared
and tore through the facility forcing
the project to shut down
nichols asked the man what he meant by a
beast and a project the young man seemed
confused he said you don't remember
you're preston nichols you ran the
montauk project
[Music]
in 1984 nichols began working with a
gifted psychic named duncan cameron who
he brought to the deserted base
immediately duncan knew his way around
he recognized the buildings and knew
specific details like where the mess
hall was the more they explored the more
information duncan was able to provide
a number of disturbing experiments
happened on the property for years
duncan started to realize he was part of
them when they entered the large
transmitter building duncan went into a
trance while in this trance duncan said
he was programmed to find nickels
befriend him and then kill him and once
that objective was achieved duncan was
programmed to destroy nichols lab and
all his research
and because duncan was now aware of his
programming he was able to resist it and
back at his lab nichols used a
deprogramming technique to give duncan
back full control of his consciousness
after working with duncan for a while
preston nichols started to realize he
had been involved with the montauk
project also he just didn't know how or
why over time more of duncan cameron's
memories surfaced duncan realized he had
served aboard the uss eldridge with his
brother edward they were the two sailors
who were lost during the philadelphia
experiment wait wait hold on hold on
that experiment took place in the 40s
that's right
duncan cameron and his brother edward
had been transported from 1943 to 1983
40 years into the future
[Music]
preston nichols started to notice
strange things when he was at work
people he didn't know seemed to
recognize him he was copied on mail and
included in meetings that didn't apply
to his position in the company one day
nichols was sitting at his desk when he
felt an ache in his hand he looked down
at the back of his hand and he had a
band-aid covering a fresh wound a wound
he didn't have 15 minutes earlier
this happened more than a few times on
one occasion nichols even confronted the
company nurse and asked her if he'd been
there for a band-aid she said he hadn't
and had no idea what he was talking
about as time went on preston nichols
began to realize that he was living two
separate lives one day he had what he
calls an intuitive urge to visit the
basement this was a high security area
only maybe 10 people in the company had
the clearance to be there and he wasn't
one of them he reluctantly took the
elevator down he gathered himself to try
to appear natural and walked right up to
the security guard and even though he
had never been in this area and had no
idea what happened here the guard gave
him a badge with his name on it and
waved him through
whether by muscle memory or just by
using his gut nichols seemed to know
where he was going he finally arrived at
a plush office much nicer than his own
and on the large desk was a name plate
preston b nichols assistant project
director preston nichols now had real
physical evidence that he was living two
lives
one as an engineer the other as a senior
member of a top secret government
program called the montauk project by
early 1990 all of nichols memories of
the project had come back
and it was worse than he could have
imagined
about 50 years after the philadelphia
experiment a man named al bilik would
start to have glimpses visions and then
entire memories of the life of edward
cameron a young naval officer serving
aboard the eldridge with his brother
duncan cameron well wait isn't duncan
cameron the psychic working with the the
preston guy yup 40 years in the future
that's right i love it please continue
bilic wrote books spoke at conferences
and gave many interviews describing his
time on the uss eldridge while living in
the body of edward cameron aboard the
eldridge when what was called a magnetic
bottle was engaged the ship began to
slip through time in a panic albilic aka
edward cameron along with his brother
duncan jumped ship and when they landed
it was the year 2137
edward woke up in a hospital and was
being treated for radiation injuries
duncan was nowhere to be seen when his
health improved edward learned more
about the world he was now in in 2137
the geography of the united states is
vastly different florida and most of the
eastern seaboard is underwater
california is a series of islands and
the great lakes have combined into one
giant lake after a devastating nuclear
war fought between the west and russia
and china the world's population has
been reduced to 300 million people the
united states canada and most
governments were gone areas were under
local martial law and just when edward
was becoming overwhelmed he was
transported hundreds of years in the
future and arrived in the year
2749 he would spend two years living in
this time and life in the 28th century
was much different than life in the 22nd
the most obvious change was anti-gravity
technology this allowed people to live
in floating cities more than two miles
above the earth and these cities were
run by an advanced ai all interconnected
with one another and human life was easy
as long as you contributed to society
all your needs were met the ai operating
robotic equipment on the ground handled
all farming and food production hippie
communist paradise pretty much and
edward felt like people lost their
identities sure their lives were easier
but they were now mindless drones
welcome to paradise comrade then
suddenly edward felt the world shifting
again now he and his brother duncan
appeared in 1983.
when they arrived they were briefed by
government officials and told to never
discuss what happened now edward would
be going on his most important mission
of all but he would be going as albilic
[Music]
in 1990 albilic's brother duncan cameron
now had full recollection of the
philadelphia experiment and the montauk
project as did preston nichols and their
memories were terrifying back in 1967
their story of time travel and
teleportation intrigued researchers at
brookhaven national labs technicians at
brookhaven had made an interesting
discovery the men serving aboard the uss
eldridge were susceptible to mind
control this breakthrough obviously had
military applications the united states
could use this technology to tell an
enemy's army to not fight wars could be
won without losing a single life and
america could take over the planet by
controlling everybody's mind that's a
scary thought um hello they already do
it what do you mean oh come on the
government uses the news media big tech
in hollywood to turn you people into
sheep
okay look having a point of view is not
really mind control people can still
think for themselves
brookhaven scientists were excited to
get started the montauk air force
station was the perfect place it was
deserted remote and had all the
equipment they needed it even had the
largest radar antenna in the world an
antenna powerful enough to broadcast
high-powered signals for hundreds of
miles or more the goal was to broadcast
on the right frequency that could alter
and control the human mind the montauk
experiment had now begun
duncan cameron having superior psychic
abilities was key to the project he was
able to withstand a tremendous amount of
electromagnetic energy and this was
necessary to survive the montauk chair
the montauk chair was essentially a
mind-reading device it was a large metal
chair covered in coils and sensors and
also connected to the chair were three
receivers six channels and a cray
supercomputer if you sat in the montauk
chair your psychic abilities could be
tremendously amplified whatever image
was in your mind was displayed on the
computer screen the first tests were to
see what would happen when cameron was
electrocuted with different amounts and
frequencies of energy they learned that
different frequencies could elicit
different emotions and specific
frequencies could make him sleep that
could be useful animals in the area were
also affected by transmissions there
were reports of deer running out of the
woods into town and throwing themselves
against the glass windows of the stores
on main street soon they were able to
perform what researchers called the
seeing eye if cameron had a lock of
someone's hair or some personal object
he could see through that person's eyes
hear through their ears and feel
whatever that person's body felt he
could do this with anyone on the planet
very similar to what remote viewers can
do using duncan cameron's psychic
abilities and the technology at montauk
scientists were finally able to control
people's thoughts then they learned how
to load information commands and entire
programs onto an individual's mind and
this technique could be adjusted to make
people do things they wouldn't normally
do assassination sabotage even
self-sacrifice if that was the mission
over time the experiments became even
more advanced cameron was now able to
manifest physical objects with his mind
if he thought of an apple or a baseball
the object would appear first on the
computer screen then holographically and
then finally as an actual solid object
in the real world this breakthrough
would lead the researchers of the
montauk project to their main experiment
using a huge new antenna and multiple
transmitters they could create a vortex
a vortex that someone could step through
and into another time
[Music]
dr john van neumann was one of the great
mathematicians of his time he also made
contributions to physics computer
science economics quantum mechanics and
lots more naturally the united states
put him to work on the manhattan project
as well as many other top-secret
government programs dr van neumann died
young of cancer in 1958 but that turned
out to be a lie he was actually placed
in a program similar to witness
protection to hide his identity and
preston nichols was able to find him and
talk to him about the experiments in
montauk and how they connected to the
philadelphia experiment van neumann now
an old man had been waiting 40 years for
this very moment he said when the uss
eldridge reappeared after the experiment
it was fatal to most of the crew van
neumann knew how to fix this
one of the ship's power generators had
malfunctioned during the experiment this
is why so many men died but if someone
could go back and disable the faulty
generator the ship would come back
properly and no lives would be lost
albilic and duncan cameron were selected
to go but they were nervous about it dr
van neumann told them not to worry he
knew this would work according to the
ship's records they had already
succeeded back in montauk duncan sat in
the chair and created a portal to the
uss eldridge in 1943 duncan and his
brother jumped back onto the ship and
disabled the generator edward decided to
stay in 1943 and when duncan returned
back to montauk something had happened
as many jumps through time and caused
him to age very rapidly and he was now
dying of old age now this could be a
disaster because duncan is linked to so
many events in the past that paradoxes
could form to prevent these disasters
the montauk technology was used to send
a message through time to duncan's
father duncan cameron senior at that
point duncan senior only had one child a
daughter but he was instructed to get
busy and make baby boys because a lot
depended on it when duncan jr was born
in 1951 the montauk scientists used the
boy as a vessel for duncan's current
electromagnetic signature this would
ensure continuity of the timeline
without paradoxes and using a similar
technique called age regression edward
cameron's consciousness was installed
into the body of young albilic now if
you're finding this hard to follow
you're not the only one all these
paradoxes and time travel missions were
weighing on preston nichols he started
to feel like he was doing more harm than
good to the people in the program to the
planet and to space time itself he
decided it was time to shut down the
program and for just the scenario the
montauk project had a contingency
protocol someone quietly walked up to
duncan while he was in the chair and
whispered the time is now
the phrase worked and a nightmare
followed
upon hearing the words the time is now
duncan cameron unleashed a monster from
his subconscious but it wasn't in the
lab it was somewhere on the base preston
nichols describes it as at least 10 feet
tall hairy and vicious it was tearing
through the base attacking everything in
its path nickel supervisor ordered the
power generators shut down but that had
no effect the creature was still
wreaking havoc building after building
the montauk transmitter was shut down
that didn't work the main power coming
from the utility company was cut that
didn't work power was still on being
generated from somewhere and worst of
all the creature was still on the loose
nichols grabbed an acetylene torch and
went to the building that housed the
transmitter control unit he yanked out
every wire he could reach the building
lights went out but the transmitter
continued to work and he could hear
distant screams coming from somewhere on
the base nichols then took the torch to
the transmitter itself
he cut wires conduits even large chunks
of equipment he destroyed everything he
could he says the burn marks can still
be seen to this day finally the portal
duncan cameron created closed and the
creature vanished and for preston
nichols this would be the end of the
montauk project but for many of the
victims this was only the beginning
[Music]
since the late 1940s and early 50s
the government has had the capacity to
what i call bend time
the montauk project ran from the early
70s until 1983 and the story does sound
far-fetched but there are many people
who say preston nichols is telling the
truth while the montauk project was
operating it needed a constant supply of
people for its experiments unfortunately
most of these were children usually boys
between 10 and 15 years old these
children became known as the montauk
boys montauk boys were usually runaways
were taken from troubled homes like
families suffering alcoholism drug
addiction or abuse one of the montauk
boys is named stuart swerdlow and as a
boy swerdlow recalls having dreams of
waking up in a dark room strapped to a
hospital bed surrounded by strangers and
the room was dark and damp and the walls
were made of rock and preston nichols
did say that the experiments took place
deep underneath the montauk air force
base one disturbing goal of the montauk
project was to create an army of
children whose minds could be programmed
and controlled then they could be
activated at any time they would carry
out any mission no matter how horrible
and not remember any of it montauk boys
have been linked to events like
columbine and the oklahoma city bombing
in order to prepare the children for
programming their minds had to be broken
down this included starvation and
torture they received electric shocks
they were submerged in cold water to the
point of almost drowning this was done
day after day until the child's mind was
ready to accept new programming and many
other men have come forward claiming to
be one of the montauk boys one said he
was forced to take lsd in what became
known as the acid house another said his
body was used as a sort of generator to
feed psychics sitting in the montauk
chair usually dunking cameron as you
would expect many children did not
survive this phase of the experiment and
they're said to be buried somewhere deep
under the base still presumed missing
after 40 years
[Music]
they wanted
a large number of program boys to be
used
for mind control operations
the experiments at montauk affected
everything in the area television and
radio signals were disrupted animals
behaved strangely in 2008 this
animal washed up on the beach at montauk
it's been called the montauk monster
what is this
now i should also point out that
directly across the long island sound is
plum island the location of the animal
disease center rumors say this island
has been used for animal experiments
biological weapons and even testing
human animal hybrids could this animal
have come from plum island what's
interesting is the cdc center for
disease control is part of america's
health and human services department
plum island allegedly a scientific
research facility is part of homeland
security
maybe we need to do an episode on this
back to montauk christopher garritano
was eight years old in 1983
and playing on montauk beach he found
strange metal objects in the sand he dug
them out and was walking back to his
family to ask what they were then out of
nowhere someone in a military uniform
appeared and chased them off the beach
this started a lifelong obsession for
garritano and he would visit the base
many times and during these visits he
would find problems with the
government's official story the montauk
air force base is not supposed to have
underground levels garritano notes that
there are manhole covers all over the
property now sure those could be used
for drainage but on one trip garatano
brought a geophysicist along and using
imaging equipment they proved that a
large concrete building was buried 20
feet down and many people have explored
the buildings over the years and a few
have video video that shows evidence of
an underground complex that was buried
and filled by concrete during one visit
urban explorer brian minnick found
receipts from the late 1980s that showed
over 80 thousand dollars per week was
spent on food that's a lot of food for a
base that was supposedly shut down in
1981 preston nicholls stewart swerdlow
al bilik chris garritano bryan minik the
names go on and on there are dozens of
people maybe more all claiming to be
part of the same experiment the us
government denies all of it who do you
believe
i'm standing today
to think of those who did not survive
and whose families will forever live
with the
knowledge that their death
and suffering
was preventable i was the subject in
radiation as well as mind control and
drug experiments performed by a man i
knew as dr green what the united states
government did was shameful
dr greene was using me mostly as a mind
control subject from 1966 to 1973.
what was done
cannot be undone
his objective was to gain control of my
mind and train me to be a spy assassin i
am
sorry the next year i was sent to a
lodge in maryland called deep creek
cabins to learn how to sexually please
men
i was taught how to coerce them into
talking about themselves only you have
the power
to forgive
the montauk project has probably been my
favorite conspiracy since preston
nichols book first came out in 1992 i
spent a lot of my life on long island so
a conspiracy that takes place in your
backyard is hard to resist i've been to
the air force base which is now called
camp hero and this story has affected a
lot of people the original title of the
show stranger things was called montauk
and a lot of stories are taken from
nichols writing this episode was
difficult to research and write because
the more i learned about my favorite
conspiracy theory the less i liked the
people involved first albeelic
he's the man who said he served on the
uss eldridge in 1943 in the body of
edward cameron there is no record of any
belik edward or duncan cameron serving
aboard the eldridge or brothers with
that name serving on any ship in the
navy now supporters of the theory say
their names were erased or changed by
the government
that's fair in belich's writings he used
pictures of his family edward and duncan
cameron and others they were all proved
to be untrue most suspicious of all
belichick had no memories of the
philadelphia experiment until he saw the
movie in 1984 he said the movie brought
his memories back but his story is
surprisingly similar to the movie he
also struggled with paranoia and other
psychological problems he made a meager
but sufficient living off selling cds
and merchandise and talking at ufo
conventions he died in 2007. many people
still believe his story and they claim
that the government has sponsored a
disinformation campaign to discredit him
okay now stewart's wordlo he's a
character he's still around and claims
to be a montauk boy he also claims to
speak 10 languages that no one's ever
heard him speak his dna has been spliced
with aliens he's been imprisoned by the
illuminati he can see auric fields he
can travel hyperspace he's a descendant
of atlantis i can go on he's basically
been at the center of every conspiracy
theory that exists
moon bases hollow earth
people
yep even lizard people oh i create such
a wacky story well you can hire stuart
to deprogram you for a fee ah that's why
now i'm not saying the guy's a fraud but
i am saying a judge said he was and if
you google him it's not pretty who knows
maybe all his potions and vitamins and
dog treats will help you reach
enlightenment but i don't recommend
buying his products did you just say dog
treats oh yeah he sells all kinds of
stuff no speaking of selling did you
know that you could buy wi-fi's
merchandise right now what's this it's a
sponsor read be quiet we've got heckle
fish t-shirts mouse pads and hoodies we
got this this is not a good time for
this link's below i've saved preston
nichols for last there were rumors
circulating about montauk for a long
time before nichols came along but
preston nichols is the main man behind
the current theory and he's the only man
behind it he actually opens his first
book like this
this word is being presented as
non-fiction as it contains no falsehoods
to the best knowledge of the authors
however it can also be read as pure
science fiction
if that is more suitable to the reader
there are a lot of things that don't add
up nichols says the montauk experiment
took place 10 stories below ground maybe
lower and that there are tunnels deep
underground that connect to other secret
locations in the united states now that
might work in some parts of the u.s but
it won't work in montauk when glaciers
move they pick up all kinds of sand dirt
and debris kind of like a push broom and
when the glaciers recede the debris
remains and this is called a glacial
moraine long island is essentially a
pile of glacier debris mostly sand you
just can't dig very deep there this is
why the only skyscrapers in the area are
downtown manhattan that's where the
bedrock is nothing else can support deep
digging but there's one final conspiracy
about preston nichols we need to discuss
and if you have little ones watching
please send them away for a few minutes
really
[Music]
okay
you might remember preston nichols used
a deep programming technique on duncan
cameron well nichols describes this
technique in his books though it rarely
makes it into the fun youtube videos
about the montauk project
to be deprogrammed preston nichols has
to touch you while you're in
an aroused state now i won't give the
specifics here but i think you
understand what i mean
and nichols deprogrammed a lot of young
men all the time preston nichols had
built a replica of the montauk chair and
the research room an eyewitnesses said
nichols would go into the room with a
man usually in his early 20s there'd be
some noise about 20 or 30 minutes later
the young man would come out disheveled
often with an uneasy look on his face
and nickels would be covered in sweat at
one point nichols was deprogramming as
many as 25 montauk boys a few times a
week who he unfortunately called
disciples and they all shared a house
not far from nichols and nobody knows
exactly how many men or deep programming
sessions were involved but it was a lot
now in the books about the montauk
project preston nichols is a man caught
up in a conspiracy greater than he could
imagine he lives a double life he meets
famous scientists he makes breakthroughs
in technology that exist only in science
fiction in these stories he's a hero
but the truth is preston nichols is a
villain because of the proliferation of
the montauk project theory dozens of men
most of whom had a mental illness
addiction issues suffered child abuse or
all the above believed they were part of
this conspiracy this delusion gave their
lives meaning
and it gave them someone to blame that
wasn't themselves or their families
and being a montauk boy gave them a
place to belong a new family of people
who understood the pain of what they
were going through and here was preston
nicholls to the rescue
able to deprogram them of all the
negative experiences they suffered from
the experiment preston nichols took
advantage of these young men for years
while other liars and frauds helped him
weave a rich complex narrative a
narrative that still continues and this
conspiracy is believable because the
government has done most of the awful
things nichols claims drugging people
against their will kidnapping torture
they've done all of this and worse the
government also spent a lot of resources
exploring psychic phenomena the montauk
project is a conspiracy grounded in a
whole lot of facts but when preston
nichols al bilik and stuart swerdlow
added their own details like time travel
aliens and conjuring monsters out of
thin air they built a house of cards
none of their stories can exist without
the other if we're able to debunk just
one small detail of any one of their
stories
the house of cards made of fraud and
abuse collapses and then all that's left
are the victims
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share that
stuff really helps the channel and
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible and if you'd like
to support the y-files please consider
joining our patreon or buying some
wi-fi's merchandise links are below
that's going to do it until next time be
safe be kind
and know that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you